let's go to our caller from the 4-1 to
area code 401 to I think is sometimes
Pittsburgh always want to hear from you
know the now not Rust Belt but more well
what is Pittsburgh I guess it's somewhat
of a more industrial city maybe the
caller's not even from Pittsburgh I
don't know who's there
this is Otis from Pittsburgh okay but is
what's going on and actually Pittsburgh
is known more now for health and
technology okay I apologize the city
here oh that's alright that's alright I
mean that's it's common and I mean it
was that way forever so it's
understandable education as well I
should add and it's known as the pits at
any rate as well
exactly yeah well which technically
people do everywhere right for good like
so I'm completely off on all of these
things all right what's going on oh no
not at all and I want to apologize
because you may have covered this and
I've missed it but apology I wanted to
talk to him I wanted to talk about the
Matthew Whitaker opinion slash
announcement about the Muller
investigation should be wrapping up
quickly yeah I work from home so I was
watching that live as it took place and
my immediate opinion and I think you'll
agree with this but my immediate opinion
in reaction to that was he was clearly
trying to set an expectation for Trump
errs that if this thing isn't wrapping
up soon that there's some type of
malfeasance or digging or delaying or
dragging going on that they should be
upset about as yeah start demanding for
this investigation to come to an end
when stone was just indicted yes yeah
yeah yeah no you're spot-on
I did I did cover this earlier in the
week and my view is basically that
number one the speech was bizarre he was
all sweaty maybe he has a condition that
makes him sweat but it seemed like he
was it was like flop sweat to me he was
Network and looked confused
and yeah I mean there haven't been leaks
from Muller it's really hard for me to
imagine that Muller would sit down with
Whitaker particularly given that
Whitaker has publicly said that if given
the chance he would try to obstruct such
an investigation and say hey Matthew you
know what we're almost done and that
then Witter Whitaker goes out and says
that and in particular a pre-dawn raid
of Roger Stone's house a week ago so
that he doesn't destroy evidence that
wouldn't normally be the thing you would
do if that's going to be like the last
indictment or the last person that might
be getting indicted it all stinks to me
yeah absolutely
glad we're in agreement I thought you
would be as well all right thanks for
the call really appreciate it good to
hear from you